how you doing buddy hey i'm doing well
rich can you hear me fine yeah man
perfect um so i'm curious about the
course but there's a few things that
really stick out to me
kind of just like recently i've been in
the workforce for
well i'm 32 now i'm kind of starting to
reevaluate what i want to do in life and
kind of where my passions really lie
um
based out of vancouver so that's another
another thing about the city too is kind
of where i'm based at
um there's a few things that i started
to really think about when it does come
to starting my own business or just
going down this path and one thing
that's kind of all that
i'm always stuck on is analysis
paralysis i feel like that
there's ideas that come to me you know
they seem great at one point and then i
give them maybe 30 minutes or maybe half
a day i think about it or run it past
some people
and
sometimes it leaves sometimes i'm still
stuck on it
are you self-employed right now are you
working for somebody no i'm working for
somebody else so i'm looking to go
outside of that route i want to
kind of drive drive drive by myself i am
a more diy person so that's kind of why
this is really sticking out to me okay
so the idea of having a proper vetting
process um feasibility scaling things
forward and also developing a proof of
concept is something that i'm kind of
like stuck on and
wondering how do i get over
well i can summarize myself well i can
summon it free this way i mean
there's
stuff in the modules that cover
different versions of that as it kind of
expands into different areas but
it it's it's far better to
deliver an imperfect product
first
than to take too much time to deliver
something that's absolutely perfect
right um
you know that that whole analysis
paralysis is is something that's going
to
it just it just sucks a lot of
perfectionists into this like crazy
vortex of [ __ ]
and yeah like
like i'll tell you the story i mean i
share it in the course material too i
think but um
i had this friend that was in a forum
and he had a big
he had a big exit on a business made a
[ __ ] ton of money he didn't really need
money and he went and created this new
business with his partners
um and i think for almost two or three
years
every forum meeting how's everything
going you know where are you going with
things you know like the updates sort of
come and it's like
the products never released and they're
always working on it they're always
tweaking it and they're always working
on they're always tweaking it and i said
in one day i go dude
you know you're 40 you're burning
through cash
sorry you're burning through personal
cash then he's also burning through cash
in the business at a burn rate of like
60 grand a month because it was him two
other people and a couple of coders um
and i was like some some 20 year old
with
exactly the same idea with a case of red
bull and a bunch of boners is gonna
[ __ ] fly right by you
and put it out to market first and
destroy you right and it's like yeah
you're right so so he put it out like
within about 30 days of that so
don't get too caught up in like the
perfection like the absolute perfection
of the product deliver something like
i'll tell you right now
i i don't know if anybody has
any issues with the course material like
as it stands i mean i gave it to my
internal
community about three weeks ago and
about you know 25 of them bought it i
gave them a nice coupon code because
they're community members um and
everybody had good things to say right
so i don't know if if something's not
working on that but if it's not working
that's cool
i'll fix it next time
right like if i miss something that's
cool i'll add another module next time
like it's far better for me to ask for
ask for forgiveness
than to ask for the permission of
everybody that i'm delivering exactly
what everyone wants because i'm not
going to make everybody happy i mean you
know if enough people say hey you know
what i really wish that you would have
spent some time on this thing all right
i'll add that to the next module and
i'll make it free to the ones that
already bought it right you know
that comes down to product development
at that point you're you're iterating it
at that point and improving on it
further it's just i think i think it's
like the initial hump of trying to get
over and thinking okay this is a good
idea or this is a terrible idea i don't
think this is going to scale i think
that's kind of where
i feel
oh i feel i get stuck on sometimes just
because it's uh
you know what i feel i think right yeah
let's let's remove the feelings out of
this but that's kind of the uh the
thought process sometimes it's yeah so
yeah so just don't get too caught up in
your head right like just just get it
delivered like you know like
a lot of these silicon valley guys will
set the bar in the sand as a
mvp minimum viable product right
does it does it work a lot of them
they'll even raise capital or they'll or
they'll take investors on with a
wireframe where they don't even have a
working like it's just the screen like i
don't know if you know what a wireframe
is but yeah basically yeah just the the
idea itself what's yeah it's just the
idea like you can navigate around and
you can click on things but there's no
software behind it so all they do is
they basically show you you know what it
looks like it's like the outside of a
house with nothing on the inside
basically right so
it it's pretty common in the business
world to just you know make sure that
you get a viable product out again it
doesn't have to be perfect just just get
something that's working out
[Music]
yeah all right cool thank you all right
man
thanks
you